In the middle of the tunnel, there was a dead bird.
This made Thumbelina very sad because she loved birds and their music.
She covered the bird with the blanket.
Thumbelina heard its heart beating!
It was still alive but very weak.
She warmed the bird with the torch and gave it grains.
Spring came and Thumbelina took care of the bird.
When the sun warmed the earth, the little hole above the bird grew larger.
"Thank you," said the bird. "I will fly to the warmer places."
"Ride on my back and I will take you!"
She jumped on the bird's back and they flew away.
The bird said, "I will take you to a nice flower."
"There is a small person like you living in every flower."
"They are called 'the spirits of the flowers'."
The bird put her next to the King of the Flowers.
He fell in love with her and gave his crown to her.
"Will you marry me and be my queen?"
Thumbelina was so happy. The flower spirits gave her silver wings.
Now, she could fly to each flower.
She soon married the King of the Flowers.
The bird was happy for Thumbelina, but sad.
He loved her, too.
Later that summer, the bird flew to Denmark.
It sang a song about Thumbelina there.
A writer heard the song. He wrote this story down.